this is a production of cornell
university
welcome everybody this is episode three
of the cornell turf show
uh season three
uh today our guest is dr kevin frank of
michigan state
um we're gonna talk to kevin about some
winter injury things we talked about
this last week and
it continues to be uh one of the big
issues we're seeing on golf courses so
excited to get to that conversation uh
but first we'll get to the other dr
frank uh frank rossi as always you've
got some uh some thoughts for us to
start us off this episode and and kevin
we taught the great lakes school and
everybody kept saying
kevin and frank and we didn't know who
they were talking to so thanks for
taking the time thanks carl welcome
everyone to our uh second golf show and
of course it's going to be dominated by
what's dominating the conversation in
golf and we're really fortunate to have
kevin here who's whether he likes it or
not is stuck with this as an expert uh
now and i and i think when you think
back about sort of the foundational work
done uh in
um winter injury it was done by dr beard
in the 60s
back at michigan state so how about a
smile for our dogs uh i you know always
grab one
chase uh has a dog that decided to pass
on the collar hope he's in uh for more
of managerial role
but still comes in every day just love
when the uh the dogs have very specific
jobs uh that they're tending to and you
know you you want to get a golf course
superintendent emotional about something
talk to them about their dog
okay carl it's all yours our
environmental research project needs
another update in the outreach and
education center session yeah so we're
going to continue with our bmp tips of
the day um and on our poster you'll see
uh one of the tips we actually have in
the water section is is let it letting
data tell the story and
uh on this poster we talk about using
evapotranspiration data et data to guide
your irrigation decision making
um but there's other types of data we
can use and i saw this really
interesting data this is from chris
tritibala the superintendent at
hazeltine national
and this is essentially him taking
uh smoothness measurements every single
day on his putting greens so we call
this the bobble test you rate it one to
ten but he's using this data to figure
out how long after a disruptive practice
do i get back to kind of my ideal level
of smoothness so he likes to be
at a nine or better for for his golfers
a very uh
avid and experienced golfing group at
hazel t national so that's sort of his
standard you could say the haze
hazeltine standard is a nine
and as frank's drawing here you can see
the amount of time there's a heavy sand
top dressing there early in may
and you see it takes almost two weeks
for the greens to get back to a
smoothness level that they deem uh as
their threshold their standard um and so
this is an interesting concept uh you
know thinking about how many days can i
give my golfers
the greens that they expect and that
they want um and as we get
further into the season here i know
people are going to want to get out and
maybe do some some of these disruptive
practices whether that's top dressing uh
poking some holes here and there
uh just just being aware of maybe this
idea of how many days can i give my
golfers really great playing services
and if you do those disruptive practices
and
in the shoulders of the season there's
certainly times when you when you're
when you should do that but it's going
to take longer to recover the grass
isn't growing at the same rate right so
these these these prolonged times of
less than ideal uh conditions maybe you
should take that into account if it
takes three weeks to recover from
aeration in the fall but only two weeks
in the summer can you start talking to
your golfers about how many days they
would be getting good greens and maybe
being able to convince them
doing this at a time where it recovers
faster it is going to help them
uh overall over the course of the season
so taking some of this data i think this
is a great idea you can follow chris has
the blog series coming out he's
releasing kind of
once a week once every other week uh his
thoughts on on this sort of data i
encourage you to check that out i'll
throw that in the chat and that'll be
at the bottom of the youtube video here
but a good way to think of data and and
how to use it to your advantage
okay carl well let me uh go back and set
up the winner issue again uh just to
remind everybody
you know moisture is a critical part of
this thing in our neck of the woods you
go out to where chrysler you know is in
nebraska you go out to the places where
kevin's from in north dakota
uh they got a totally did they got the
other issue that they don't have enough
water they get no snow and they've got
wind issues although looks like the old
dakotas had their fair amount of
moisture when you consider to fall
till early march right this is last fall
through early march
now from the northeast right again this
is a slide i used last week just you
know to remind you we had some places
that were in excess of 150 to 200
percent of normal
throughout the northeast at the same
time we heard from art d guytano our
climate center director today that
actually parts of the northeast are
starting to get dry almost into drought
conditions
over that december to march period so it
wasn't wet for everybody and certainly
when i look at where the injury was i
don't know that this particular data
indicates how wet it was but it
certainly there certainly were parts of
the northeast that were significantly
wet
and here's that drought uh condition
that art talked about this is the
update from last week right it gets
updated on thursday after i do the uh
show here with carl and and you can see
uh this area up north continues to be
dry and we're really starting to see the
philadelphia southern new jersey areas
where they got really sandy soils too
you get down to that part of the pine
barrens of new jersey you're pretty
sandy down there uh which could make the
conditions worse so
when it comes to moisture i will tell
you i visited a golf course this uh week
that said that i visited winter injury
damage on and said the greens where they
put these drainage in these old porsche
polar greens where they put these xgd
lines in did not experience injury now
i don't know if you know kevin will tell
you this isn't something you can know
every time if this is gonna work the way
it did but in this case this one golf
course they had six greens they put the
xgds in and those were greens that would
normally have some damage and this year
did not have it so obviously there's
something to be said uh for improving
drainage now when you look at winter
injury patterns this is some winter
injury from the black horse back in 2003
right and you can see in the middle of
the 16th green here when you've got
these big
bold shape areas
where you get water accumulating and
staying longer um you know this is a
this is an easy pattern to see right i'm
trying to set this up so that you can
see well there are some patterns here
now the other pattern we talked about
last year were these freezing and
thawing cycles right it warms up there's
standing water
the the water gets hot passes it into
the soil
right in this case it's excluding the
moisture it's getting some air in there
but when
when you break dormancy
right when you break dormancy this is
work out of the prairie research center
we talked about last week at four annual
bluegrass ecotypes you know experiencing
different warm-ups for different lengths
of time and you see
the dramatic drop
right this plant went from 50 of the
plants dying at minus 24
to 50 percent of the plants dying at 17
degrees so it's going to be eco-type
related right it's going to be how long
it was warm related it's going to be
moisture related
right this is our 18th hole on the
cornell golf course right what looks
like a clear water path right a clear
path where water was trying to get off
the green
but this is something kev i got a
picture off of one of your blog posts in
14. i'm going to bring this up when we
get to chatting but the interesting
question is what is dead
right what color i mean look at this you
got brown you got yellow you got sort of
yellowy green
right you got some dark green there's
all different colors here
and then you look close and like
you know wishful thinking is it dead is
it alive here's what i can tell you
all uh all of this grass
is injured in some way
now the extent of its injury is going to
determine the conversation for today
what can we expect from recovery right
so before you go we go crazy like trying
to recover the question comes up huh my
green looks like this my proxy thing
says it's time
should we be making
growth regulator applications
to these surfaces uh that are damaged
now if you don't have a damaged surface
kevin's gdd tracker and our tracker
seems to indicate even up into the
finger links we're in an ideal time
for the spring application again
hopefully you made a fall application of
course it's an interesting question if
you made a fall application how does it
help recovery or hinder recovery but
this is a topic of discussion the timing
is saying it's good if you know you're
not injured obviously this would be an
ideal time to make up and going the
wrong way to make that application now
the solution to this is not have poland
but unfortunately that's not really an
option for most people so when you go to
surfaces and in this particular case you
see the damage daniel bluegrass and you
can see the bank grass really just
thriving here with with no problem at
all and again we talked about it last
week this is one of those achilles heels
of
annual bluegrass is keeping it alive uh
through the winter
so here we are we're getting in the
season and it still looks like this
right so kevin one of the things that i
want to talk about is you know how do we
get it moving faster well clearly
covers is one way to go here and of
course we know what covers are doing
they're driving up the temperature there
so what are we expecting what did we get
and what are we expecting temperature
wise
we've been warmer than normal the last
week was as much as 10 and 12 degrees
above normal in some places around
normal closer to the coast right
impacted by the the the ocean cooling it
off a little bit but inland we were as
much as 12 to 14 degrees above normal
which which was good
but it's not good looking forward the
degree day accumulation moving forward
is in the single digits which is not a
good forecast for accumulating heat i
pulled this particular uh
look at sky cover you can go to the
national forecast center and look at how
much sun you're gonna get right and then
you realize why on earth kevin and carl
and i live in the most miserable places
uh in the world where the sun doesn't
shine kevin is one of those few people
that lives in a university at a cloudy
place like we do but obviously this is
going to be a significant component
even if the air is warm
to really accelerate these conditions
you got to have sun
so uh not only are we not going to have
sun it doesn't appear it looks like
we're going to get a ton of rainfall
particularly along the coastline you're
looking at one to two inches
over the next several days of precip
around a half an inch to an inch just
about everywhere else
you look at these forecasts the next two
days are going to be wet the weekend's
going to be about an inch inch and a
half a total precip a good thing we're
not sitting out in the middle of the
atlantic we could be getting as much as
three or four inches if that storm moved
inland a little bit so
you know this is not necessarily what we
need for ideal recovery
um and soil temperatures honestly have
not budged carl since last week when we
talked about this we're still in the mid
to
mid 50s at its peak and it's getting
into the 50s up the hudson valley but
you come up here but we've got a lot of
damage we've got still got soils in the
upper 30s and 40s
now of course we control is one of those
things you use temperature for and you
know those maps are kevin keeps them on
the degree day tracker i'd encourage you
to go look at them but if we're talking
about heat kevin now i'm setting you up
buddy this is what i'm seeing guys doing
it's like you know how much is dead let
me try these covers they put a couple in
some spot areas
right and and uh you let me see let me
get this some people are going for black
sand
right this is an easier way to go maybe
not as labor intensive you look closer
you can really see
uh the the sort of increase that you get
and so here he is we don't have to show
him uh in this great blog post that he
did in 14 and kevin here's the picture
you used kid you know this is what it
looked like in april of 2014.
you know what what's gonna come back and
and it looks like your predictions were
okay
what was dead was dead and what you
thought would come back would come back
so listen i'm gonna stop sharing and and
just
you know first i'd ask you just simply
to comment on you know what what you
heard me yeah about uh and and and then
take us on a little journey
for what
superintendents experiencing this damage
are gonna have to deal with trying to
get these things recovered
thanks frank just uh just to clarify did
you call me kid just a little while ago
because if if so i appreciate that i
don't pretty much anymore
so i'll call you kid i'll call you
brother i do all sorts of 70s lingo
so i guess that's that's refreshing um
you know it's it's interesting what's
going on we we haven't had uh as far as
i know we've had a little bit of spotty
damage around this area but we haven't
had any
um real significant winter kill that i'm
aware of but
those temps you're talking about um
you're talking about the precipitation
totals and stuff coming um
we're talking in the solid form although
they're saying it's not going to stick
around in the next
couple days but they're talking snowfall
um so that gives you an idea of the
challenge that winter kill
reestablishment presents is just those
soil temps you know if you're in the
30s in areas or just creeping up in the
40s um i i still think
when you you know first of all what's
dead
i i have i have no
you know maybe i'm a good guesser but
from what i've seen over the years if
it's like those white colors where it's
completely bleached
i think it's gone
um those are the ones that i those are
the areas that i look and go you got to
have a plan anything that's you know
brownish toastier
at least in this area like where we deal
with i don't think it's generally dead
now you get to the plane states where i
guess they've had a bunch of desiccation
injury this year that sounds pretty
disastrous
everything out there is just brown brown
it's dead but we deal more with these
moisture issues um
you know you can try to assess it you
know as many soups have done you know
bring it bring a core in heat it up in
your your shop and you get a quick
assessment probably faster and you're
gonna get
out in the field um
i still think when it comes to
re-establishment it's a
get things going sooner rather than
later um
one of the big challenges of course can
just be soil moisture of like how are
you gonna how are you gonna prep that
dead seed bed so to speak um and whether
you're gonna be able to get in there if
it's obviously if it's soaking wet you
don't want to do damage by whether
you're
using a job saver attachment whether
you're slit seeding whether you're
verticating and dragging seed in
whatever it is okay well that that
brings to the first question right
because you know like i know
every turf manager's first move is the
poke hole
it's the first move every time
pocahontas what do you recommend
relative to poking a hole
as far as warming that whole system up
right if if heat is what's going to
drive this thing
is disturbance key to that or is it
secondary
to that
i think it depends i mean if that's all
you've got going for you
of trying to warm it up i think i'd go
ahead and open it up if you have
covers
if you have
you know you want to go out there and
put black sand on it if you want to use
just a pigment that you spray that makes
it green and camouflages it helps warms
it up
maybe i'd go ahead and do that before i
before i start prepping the seed bed but
i think i still think that also depends
you know if
if you think it's dead
i still think i'd go rather than wait
i've seen guys you know argue over this
that
you know whether it's pie in the sky or
whatever that no i don't think it's dead
i'm gonna wait
and i was like well every day you wait
you know you look at the forecast and
everybody thinks they know what's going
on and then all of a sudden you have
like here in east lansing here we had 60
degrees on monday and that really wasn't
it was supposed to be a decent day but
it wasn't supposed to be that nice now
the rest of the week is awful but
it's like you kind of take it when it
comes and if you're not if you if you
don't get prepped and get things in the
ground i mean you know you're just
delaying the inevitable i think in many
cases
so in your mind when you see that
stuff you're sure is dead
how do you then decide should i try to
um
prep it for seed or
cut it and
sod it
plug it
how do you ma what has been your
experience in making that decision
i think a lot of people start with seed
realize how long it takes give up and
sonic
so and it obviously depends on the size
of the area like like that um picture
you showed from beth page you know that
just that long slender area
something like that you know if you've
got sod if you got plugs i'd probably
get it over with and just be done with
it you know people say well it doesn't
match perfectly or you know it takes a
little while but it's just i mean
you know sometimes the best case
scenario is we as we battle through
these spring periods
you might be eight weeks before you have
anything that you feel like you can play
on you know and and that's why if it's
minor damage and you've got a big
nursery green and it's it's a bird bath
type damage or something
i think in many cases just get it done
with
so what about the covering driving up
the heat how much have you played around
with
is a pigment better than black sand
if i put black sand in a pigment does
that save me to cover
uh here's the thing that's on my mind
whenever we talk covers
you're always going to play the game
it's on and then you know you get that
60 degree day and it gets you know it
gets heating up and you start to freak
out so you pull it off and then you got
those you know stakes every two feet
then they're getting thrown somewhere
where a mower can hit them so how do you
reconcile how do you decide how to make
recommendations to folks on warming up
the system i think with covers you know
how many guys do you have on staff that
can help you yank covers all the time i
think that's a big factor um i honestly
you know we've
it's been you know
quite a few years since we tried to do
the cover reestablishment studies the
thing that we found is you might get
some benefit um
until it's out of the ground but after
after that i think it diminishes pretty
quick um pray your biggest benefit is
cold nights
you know so it's like i'm looking at our
forecast
we're in the 30s or we're in the single
not single digits we're close to it this
weekend
and then even next week it's like 30s
every night
with highs maybe around 50. um so that's
that's an awful scenario but assuming
you're a little bit warm in that if you
see those nights where it's colder i
think sometimes just that benefit of
having that cover in place overnight can
maybe help it keep going a little bit um
one of the problems with the covers is
you alluded to frank was just the
constant pull and push right so it's
like okay so you know i get out there i
establish it it's growing okay i want to
mow or i want to spray some fertilizer
or whatever you got to push pull this
thing off spray put it back on i think
you kind of run get to a point where
it's just like it's uh
you're chasing your tail so i think i
think there's there's price and benefit
initially especially when it's cold but
after that i'd probably just pull them
and get just forget it yeah because once
they get covered and they get warm
if we get those single digits
you probably have like i have seen them
get set back even further and if you
didn't do anything yeah so so and i
think the uh
you know pigment versus black sand
we played around with that um we didn't
see as much heating effect as we thought
we would with the pigment but i think it
was is probably our own fault as we
didn't continually spray the pigment and
it tended to fade on us um so i think if
you're gonna use like a green green
pigment you you need to have that
sprayed regularly and so some guys have
even complained or not complained they
said you know i started using that and
then i realized you know i can't i can't
tell what's dead anymore
because
it just camouflaged everything and it's
like that's great for maybe the golfer
or something but for the superintendent
they're going geez you know what are the
areas i need to touch up um i think the
black black sands worked great um
i had a
superintendent northern michigan one
year when i walked onto his golf course
i literally gasped um
he had he had used uh malorganite to a
level that i don't think i had ever seen
before
um
but it helped him now it's helped him
heat up you know especially as you get
northern michigan like you know frank i
mean you're sitting next to lake
michigan and stuff and it's never
warming up until june sometimes but
you also have that issue of dealing with
that nutrient load and then you know at
some point trying to you know blow that
fertilizer off to the edges or whatever
and pick it up but you know you kind of
see it all at some point anything to try
to help facilitate warming up that
surface when it's uh when weather isn't
helping us out yeah because i mean i
remember years ago uh there was a senior
men's open in uh at western country club
in salem massachusetts and they had a
massive uh
winter kill and they went out and
sprayed like 30 ounces of ferrous
sulfate and just turn the place black
to try to draw
heat to it um
you know
i want you to give me an assessment
right you're looking at the next couple
of weeks you know what you know
i want to put into people's heads here
and get on the get on the record
it's it's we could be a month to six
weeks from having a playable surface on
these sorts of damaged greens is
that a reasonable assessment if if an if
a whole green is
is damaged that you're looking at you
know four to six weeks to get it into
play i think i think that's a that's a
very optimistic assessment
i mean i'm just going back to what we
saw you know the epic event of 1314 and
1450 kind of 14 15 in the northern part
of the country
you know you look back at that weather
it's probably not a whole lot different
than it was it is right now as far as
being cold and
we had you know some cases 18 greens
wiped out
if
if they were back on them the first week
of june
it was pretty good um and certainly at
that point they weren't up to you know
insert your country club facilities name
their standards
but at least they were playing them so
that was looking at closer you know
you're what were you saying for six
weeks that was looking at maybe like six
to eight to ten
so what about inputs um you know we went
through the coring business we'll maybe
revisit that but what about input should
you be goosing them with nitrogen uh
should you be you know
starter fertilizer
what do you recommend uh that is going
to help
i think
any and all
right i mean
you're pushing growth so i i still
advocate you know just like you're
reestablishing put down on a starter
when you seed
and then i've seen it both ways of
people using more you know complete
fertilizers as they go forward or guys
just going hey
i'm just gonna as soon as it's up and
growing i'm gonna
spray it you know tenth of a pound of in
every every week
um you know throw some other stuff in
there if you want but you know i think
it's primarily nitrogen that's gonna
help you grow and you got you have to
switch the mindset from
and this is a struggle right you've got
areas of that green that are probably
just fine in areas that are dead
it's hard to you know you got a target
spray maybe a little spray hawk or
something like that but you also have to
shift that mindset that i'm now trying
to grow grass instead of manage on the
edge where i want firm fast putting
greens
and also don't forget about water
you know because you're probably going
to have to your spotty areas you're
gonna have to hand water those areas uh
you can't let it dry out right i mean
that's just number one but one of those
days you referred to where it's 65 or
whatever
and
you guys kind of forget about that spot
seed might be up but it can go in a
hurry so um but yeah i think
it's something you will have to
kind of you probably don't catch up the
rest of the year in some of these areas
i mean it's not going to be the same
because you've reestablished and you
pushed it probably more than you wanted
it to but you had to get grass i mean
that's the number one thing you got to
get grass yeah and and the worst part is
as you said
the areas that aren't damaged
if you
start doing that recovery stuff to them
now you're going to have organic matter
accumulation problems if you start
pushing growth there carl questions did
i see one come up
yeah we do have a question from from our
guy josh out in saratoga uh solid or
permeable covers and if we're talking
about the the winter injury we're seeing
this year which
seems to be it seems like less of the
the permanent ice cover and more of this
uh fluctuations in temperature what are
your opinions on those
i think it's whatever cover you have but
if i have a choice i would pray to take
the permeable
yeah okay
yeah all right so uh
kevin we got one minute buddy but you
brought up a really good point
it's probably good for superintendents
who are experiencing this to pace
themselves
right because my experience is you exert
a lot of energy to get these things back
and it's may 1st or june 1st and it
feels like september 1st
so i think what you're saying is it may
actually take most of the year to get it
back which if you've got large areas and
you've got a nursery
that may be
the tipping point right there that i can
probably get this turfed area back in
shape in two weeks three weeks versus
waiting for seed to fill in
and seeding bent grass into bent polar
greens bank grass seed's not going to
jump out of the ground if do you even
recommend throwing bankruptcy or should
we just
stir it up and let the policy do its
thing i i think you you know the studies
we've done
although you doubt
yourself bent will get in there and
we'll make a foothold by the end of the
season i think i think the thing too
frank which is very difficult um for the
superintendent they stare at every
freaking day every day and it's like
when you look at it every day and i know
you're going to it is so hard to feel
like you're making progress it's like i
would come out to a site
one week and i may go back a week later
or two weeks later and i go wow you've
made tremendous progress they look at it
and go really i hadn't noticed because i
look at it every freaking day and it's
driving me crazy you know
um if you have the sporadic damage
that's tough because you got a seat into
it if you got isolated where you can
core it you can sod it and get it over
with i'd probably just do it if you've
got the ability to do it because you're
going to be chasing your tail no matter
what it's just i haven't think the
isolated damage is easier to deal with
than when it's sporadic pot marks of poa
that died all across the green
kevin
it's so great to see you thanks for
taking the time i'm glad the windows
worked out
we're all we're all good it's not even
raining so it's a great day to replace
windows in a house all right
all right carl get us out of here yeah
thanks everybody this is uh this has
been episode three of our cornell turf
show this year also i guess doubles as a
half an hour long ad for bent grass uh
if you want to look at it that way is
one long ad for ben best but uh
thanks again for joining today tomorrow
we'll have anthony
maskiddy from penn state we're gonna be
talking about infields and work in the
dirt early in the year so uh if you're
interested in that tune in tomorrow
thanks all for joining we'll see you
next time this has been a production of
cornell university on the web at
cornell.edu